-Our next guest is a very funny
actor and comedian
who stars in the critically
acclaimed series "Search Party."
The final season
is streaming on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-We would prefer a boy.
Um, a gay baby boy.
-Or even queer. A queer baby.
-And, of course, we are
very open to all ethnicities.
Of course.
-And religions.
-But it would be ideal if they
were 5'11" at the shortest
so that they could carry us up
the stairs to bed
when we're very elderly.
-And one-blue-eye-and-one-
brown-eye baby.
Like a husky.
-But it would be also good if he
could make us feel protected
like a dad, like a son
that feels like a dad.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend John Early.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, John.
-Thank you so much, Seth.
-It's great to have you here.
-Thank you so much.
It's an honor to be here,
the hallowed halls of NBC.
-Great.
-Yeah.
-You --
-Do you mind if I sit like this?
-You can sit however you want.
But I will say, you know,
you've been on the show before.
You're a friend of the show.
You seem a little
different to me.
-What do you mean?
-Just the -- You just --
You just seem different to me.
-In what way? In what way, Seth?
-You're, like, presenting in a
way that I'm less accustomed to.
-It honestly could be that stuff
is so tough
with my girlfriend at home.
-Your -- Your -- You have a
girlfriend at home now?
-Yeah,
we just moved in together,
and I've never
shared space before.
-So this is -- Okay,
this is a little strange --
-Do you have an IPA?
-You want an IPA now?
-Can I get an IPA?
Yeah, if that's cool.
-See, here's what --
I feel like previously
when you've been on the show...
-Yeah?
-...one of the things
you've talked about the most,
which I --
you know, I got to be honest,
I enjoy is how much
sexual chemistry you and I have.
And now -- and now you're kind
of coming out with presenting --
like, all of
a sudden, there's a girlfriend.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-I'm just -- Maybe I just seem
a little off because --
I mean, as excited as I am for
the Chiefs to be at
the Super Bowl --
-What?
-As excited as I am for
the Chiefs, I'm also, like,
so pissed the Titans
didn't make it.
-Okay. Well, that's --
See, now, this is --
You're giving yourself away
a little bit.
-I might join the Marines,
as well.
-I don't know why you feel like
you have to do this.
-I'm going to drop it.
Yeah, I was just like --
-Okay, good.
-Yeah, I'm going to drop
the bit.
I was having a lot of fun,
by the way,
and I want to be clear
our chemistry was "on fleek."
But I just -- I couldn't --
I couldn't keep going
because I did want to
actually say hi.
-And it was -- It was really --
You were very believable
that whole time.
-Thank you, thank you.
I can't -- I wanna --
you know,
I really think gay people
should play straight people.
And, to be clear,
I think straight people
should play gay people.
-Alright.
-Because it's hotter.
Everyone is always up
in arms about that.
I'm like, I want to watch
Heath Ledger and Jake Gyllenhaal
go at it.
Like, don't -- don't --
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-Hey, congratulations
on the show -- five seasons.
-Thank you.
-And I want to
ask a lot about it.
-Normally, there's an
applause right there, yeah.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-But I want to
specifically ask about --
That's John Waters in the clip.
The legend, John Waters.
-The legend, my father.
-What was it like --
How was he as a scene partner?
-Oh, my God, he is such a f--
I almost wanted to say
the F-word.
He is such a professional.
He is just, like --
-Yeah.
-By F-word, by the way,
I meant F-ing professional.
I wasn't --
-Just do it so they know.
-The [bleep] professional.
-There you go.
-There's a delay, there's a
delay, there's a delay.
Sorry.
You know, I get -- I get,
you know, at 30 Rock
and then I want to --
Is Lorne watching?
You know, and I want to --
-Right, yeah.
Oh, he does. He's the producer.
He watches everything.
-He watches every night.
It's so beautiful, yeah.
-It's so beautiful.
-No, wait, John Waters.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, like, he is my --
He created the sensibility that,
like, the show lives in.
He created my entire persona,
you know, my sense of humor.
Like, so it was
very overwhelming.
I was, like -- I was in my -- I
was, like, getting choked up
in my trailer imagining,
like, talking to him.
And then you just get on set,
and he's just, like,
the most ordinary -- He's, like,
such a sweet guy and so boring.
It's such a bad story. Go home!
This whole appearance
has sucked!
-But does he go --
Does he show up being, like --
I mean, you know,
does he show up, like,
bigger than the project
or does he --
Like you said,
he's a professional. Like...
-He is such a professional.
He's so -- He's, like,
truly more off-book than me.
-Yeah.
-Like, which was humiliating.
Like, he had, like,
these long, chunky lines,
and I was, like -- I was so in
awe of what he was doing.
And then I was
just, like, "Line."
-Do you -- You know, obviously,
the scene's about
adopting a baby.
Is that -- Do you want to be
a father in real life?
-Well, I can't.
-What?
-The ban.
Like, gay people
can't have babies.
-No, no, they can. They can now.
-Well, they can't get married.
-Yeah, no, they can do both.
-Okay, I've been kind of, like,
exploiting that oppression
for all of my career, and now...
-Oh.
-And now you're saying
the door is open?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
How are your kids?
-They're great.
-Good.
How does that feel?
-What?
-To be asked a question
for once in your life?
I'm sorry. Sorry. I'm sorry.
I'm getting -- I get hostile.
I get hostile when I'm nervous.
I lash out.
-You mentioned being
in the building 30 Rock.
You were also --
Your first TV show.
-Yeah.
-For first TV job was "30 Rock."
-Yeah. It was -- I was such
a huge fan of "30 Rock."
Another -- Jane Krakowski
also fully created me.
-Yeah.
-You know what I mean?
Like, I would not --
Like, I owe it all to her.
And my mom.
Um, sorry, sorry.
But, yeah, so,
I got the job to play, like,
one of her, like,
test-tube babies.
-Wow.
-And I was so excited.
I had never done anything
on TV and I was so excited,
and I had like
five, maybe six lines.
And I was, like --
I was so amped up and so, like,
trying to get them to notice me.
Like, I was just, like, creating
this narrative of, like,
"I'm going to go on for this,
like, day-player role,
and Tina is
going to be like, 'It's him.'"
And so every scene, even though
I'm like one of six
of her kids in this --
like, in this --
the conceit
of that episode, like --
And everyone was so
professional and, like, still
as she's, like, talking to
a group of six people.
And it's --
So, it's like five models,
and then me over here, like...
I'm, like, just -- I'm like...
in every scene.
And then I had a full --
It was so, like,
life-changing to be on that set.
And then I had,
like, a viewing party,
like, with a group of friends.
And I was like, "Get ready.
Like five, maybe six lines,
but I did a lot of improv.
They'll probably work that in."
And then everything had been cut
except for one three-word line.
-So, this is --
I want everybody here
to imagine they're at
John's viewing party.
And John is expecting --
You're thinking
minimum five, maybe 15 lines.
-Maybe -- Yeah, maybe 15.
And they're going to
cut to me, you know,
because of all the
physical stuff I was doing.
-And this was
the entirety of it.
Let's take a look.
-Yeah.
-I didn't want to say anything
because I was trying to be
a good mother,
but you're cheesy,
and everyone hates you.
-No, Jenna, you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, I saw it.
-Thank you.
I mean,
it was crushing at the time,
but look at me now.
-Look at you now.
This is very exciting.
First of all, congratulations.
The fifth season is fantastic.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You have to watch it.
-"Search Party"
is streaming on HBO Max.
And you're going to
stick around,
and Aidy Bryant
is going to come back.
We'll see you right after
this commercial break.
-Thank you, Seth.
[ Cheers and applause ]